kevin booker starred in the first round
against the playoffs at a 47-point
clinch in game six the second round paul
was at his very best
and here in the western conference
finals they had a lot of help from a lot
of people
chris paul acknowledging little wayne
and the support
that he has shown the love he has shown
to the phoenix sons believing in them
supporting them being around them he
wants to be part of this celebration
41 points and devin booker
after having some struggles earlier in
the series
excellent game tonight with 22 points
but they got jake crowder
with a big performance he had 19.
and paul's going to enjoy this before he
gets set remember chris paul in
game one of these playoffs injured his
right shoulder people are starting to
say oh no another injury for chris paul
and the first three games of that series
was a struggle
but he came back strong was magnificent
against denver
then missed two games in this series
after testing positive for culvert
struggled a little bit in the first
couple of games back
but a brilliant performance here in game
six